freunde herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video wir fahren heute nach düsseldorf
in die top fünf spots zu testen ich habe
euch nach empfehlungen gefragt ich habe
freunde nach empfehlung gefragt und ich
glaube wir können uns auf den tag heute
freuen abgesagt düsseldorf wo wir den
tag mit einem burger starten erst das
wort einladen den ich schon immer mal
testen wollte ich habe so viel davon
gehört heute liegen wir in den ohren
dass das einer der krassesten bürger
sein soll die man bekommen kann food
brother ihr wisst es gibt verschiedene
bürger kategorien so die gesunden die so
vollkommen also die mächtigen die so
richtig groß werden und dann gibt es so
die diese zu einem verschmelzen diese
klassischen american bürger das ist
letzteres und ich bin sehr gespannt wie
er sein wird wir werden jetzt einmal den
klassiker einen normalen cheeseburger
bestellen und einen nachschub burger der
ist nämlich dauerbrenner hier habe ich
mir sagen lassen geheimtipp beide testen
hier und ich bin sehr gespannt wie sich
sprechen
[Musik]
das nicht so gut aussah man sich
aufregen okay ich bin wirklich gespannt
auf diesen bürger bei ich habe ganz ganz
viel davon gehört und wir gehen erst mal
die burger checkliste durch wir haben
hier ein brötchen sehr flüssig hin drin
schön an getrost ich sehe direkt schon
das fleisch hat eine sehr schöne große
zum relativ dünne smash petty würde ich
sagen aber es sind ausser als heißt so
kein reines match hätte so senius smash
lab ist ein bisschen weg gern salat der
sehr schön hier rein gelegt wird der
alle die salate der bürger nicht fehlen
darf und wieso der käse mit dem pettyfer
schmilzt ist auch wirklich eine
augenweide stadt braucht dann auch so
ein schöner zwiebelringen ich muss sagen
das ganze erinnert mich ein bisschen an
innen out burger das gleiche anders als
in meiner heimatstadt köln nicht meine
persönlichen empfehlungen teilen kann
präsentiere ich wenn ich in anderen
städten bin auch in zukunft einfach so
nach auswahl aus empfehlungen von
freunden empfehlungen aus der community
und sachen die einfach wenn man danach
googelt und so viel zu krass aussehen
das ist ein bisschen eine mischung aus
allen drei punkten deshalb bin ich wie
gesagt sehr gespannt darauf und es liegt
auch sehr sehr krass also vom gefühl her
ultra waldraff häufig stärker noch ein
jetzt gehöre man christus auf den barren
[Musik]
erster gedanke wird dieser rindfleisch
geschmack sehr sehr groß dass
verschmitzt alles aber nicht so zu 100
man schmeckt noch die einzelnen
komponenten
das war's aber sie sind andere küsst wie
das ist so in so eine top ten freie
erfahrung weil sie so spaß machen toms
eine eher so eine mac ist kommen ist in
der solinger ok so eine dünnere aber
nichtsdestotrotz den extra level an
krank sodass du bei keinem der anderen
beiden hast also schon mal zwischen
serbe kann man nicht anders sagen manche
songs sondern wirklich sehr schöne große
auf den partikeln spannt hier beschreibt
das sieht nach einem guten bisher auch
nicht
nur
eine sehr gelungene bürger kreation bei
lost gehört was wir ja das sind die halt
wieder klappt so ein bürger dafür nicht
bestellen sondern weil in nadschaf
bleiben nicht ewig nur verbrennen aber
hunden nicht wo carlo creme habe ich
gerade gesehen sehr schöner burger
anschnitt meiner meinung nach richtig
schönen farben sweet chili sauce soft
bisschen unüblich auf der werft war
trotzdem echt sehr gut und man kann
wirklich nicht sagen müssen absolut
großartiger burger lang ich finde du als
kölner kann es auch den vergleich ziehen
wie ist es so wenn du jetzt deine heimat
vergleicht wo es ja auch exzellente
burger gibt vorher so abschneiden
also in köln fährt burgers die
gästeliste in ähnlichen die bürger sind
an sich noch fliehen also noch weniger
so ein blog fed den du dir ein ist es ja
auch gleich sein kann bei bürgern aber
so die haben ihren eigenen style sind
super freshen was ihr wirklich allen
voran abliefert ist die präsentation
wird ab selten so eine krasse
präsentation außerhalb von amerika auf
deutschen boden also sehr sehr geheim ab
zunächst das wort eric das geschmäckle
freunde schweren herzens stehe ich hier
vortag um fast schweren herzens nicht
weil es hier kein leckeres essen gibt
sondern weil es so leckeres essen hier
gibt das ich aber schon mal gegessen
habe und noch so viel vor mir heute das
jetzt nicht eingehen wäre ihr erinnert
euch aber vielleicht einfach super
authentischer laden ihre leckeres essen
frisch gekocht kleines ein bisschen
chicken chips und so weiter und so fort
und die besten rahmen je gegessen habe
das ist immer einen besuch wert ich fand
es so überraschend dass eine suppe
rahmen so befriedigend sein kann in bar
wie eine pizza oder so das habe ich hier
gelernt hat kuoni hat mir das
beigebracht so das ist einfach
geschmacklich eine explosion und in so
einem authentischen richtigen ambiente
das ist einfach nur spaß macht die
fersen deshalb checks gerne ab wenn du
da sagst es weiter zum nächsten fußball
[Musik]
es ist so einfach und so schön und vor
allem kommission ist es ist es ja
düsseldorf
antritt wird meister aber was nicht
wissen ob das ist der preis um zwölf
euro und das ist wirklich mehr als meine
klar wir sind ja in seiner bude so
ebenmäßig aber trotzdem carpaccio und
drücken nudeln man sieht auch so richtig
das carpaccio ist kommt mit hauchdünnen
ja wirklich kann man das ist so ist der
reis einfach so richtiger ist carpaccio
und was sehr sehr interessant ist die
nudeln werden quasi in der türke
sahnesoße gekommen dadurch nehmen die
beiden und kein wasser sondern sagen
auch gleichzeitig mit die stärke quasi
an die soße abgegeben bindet das ganze
und ich rechne mit einer sehr sehr gerne
sehr cremig hast du bist in rucola oben
drauf haben sie bei uns abgeguckt
gewandt habe authentisch keine löffel
bekommt also man muss das ganze hier so
essen mama ein bisschen carpaccio ein
bisschen rucola einen perfekten weit
fertig machen und dann probieren was sie
sich dabei gedacht haben
alter schwede brunnen kaspar kraemer und
diese gesamt kombination etwas von dem
apache oder beirat und so alter schwede
was häufig kofferraum das ist wirklich
outstanding so sticht heraus das sind
von a bis z nur gute produkte frische
pasta brückl so frisch ist kappacher
buch oder um geschmacklich auch die
frische reinzugehen
ich finde das hat auch genau die
richtige stärke so von trüffel geschmack
gefühl diesem feld rannte los so richtig
so graz dann hast du so zwei wochen kein
bock auf triple das könnte den tag es
eine perfekte note und wirklich eine
himmlische reaktion
hier bleibe
zunächst spot ist ja wirklich nicht von
dieser welt wir sind hier am karlsplatz
mitten in der keine ahnung über die
geografie vaters wird und das ist quasi
ein stationärer food markt und generell
markt und ich bekomme richtig lust wenn
ich hier bin weil ich so diesen vibe
spüre war offen street food markt zu
gehen sollen wir das mal machen und es
ist einmal komplett durch testen
schreibt man die kommentare weil ich
glaube es ist bald sogar einer und bad
essen wir das auch mal
15 euro
[Musik]
aber schick aus und ich habe mit so was
anderen gerechnet heißt du somit zu mehr
klassischen zielen schießen das ist so
steakbrötchen
effekt brüten das ist eigentlich das
highlight aber ich will nicht dass
irgendwie noch weiter grad also ich muss
das alles erst findet kräuterbutter so
sieht heldt nicht aus okay ist ein durch
nokia oder hier sind meine goldene küste
von pemba so ein stück anzuhalten das
schmeckt also ganz nicht mehr
hinbekommen
bitte darüber sprechen wie kann das es
überhaupt dass man vario in dem imbiss
bekommt so weil das ist unterm strich
ein imbiss es ist halb voll das konzept
stecke oder alles auswählen kann und
dass die möglichkeit irgendwelche stakes
direkt aus zu kaufen in die andere
hälfte des datums gegeben wollte endes
ist und dazu bereiten oder ohne aufpreis
wohlgemerkt und so auch dieses stück
wagen ist also ganz schön knusprig
gebraten es ist halt nur eine frage wird
man sich erst mal nicht das beste was
man machen kann aber es ist so ein
kleines stück gleich und probierten das
gar nicht anders geht aber ich hab sogar
15 euro vielleicht sollte man dann
überlegen ob man nicht im größeres
spektakel
ist durch probier's mal ist die pure
wirklichkeit sondern das stück war
drittschnellster in der die augen zu
aber eher leute also es ist etwas ganz
besonderes das ist einfach cool
das schriftgut das ist eigentlich besser
als zweck
aber nur fleisch in geschmack eines und
hier ja sehr sehr üppiges sandwich
saftig scheint es auf jeden fall zu sein
die wirklich dass wir sehr stolz sind
ich bin sehr gespannt darauf also sieht
gut aus sie sind nicht behindert
möglich also dass fleisches der tat eine
sehr schöne fleischige note für das ist
so herbst auch diese soße die da oben
rum ist ich sehe gar nicht so einfach in
cases schmeckt trotzdem der käseglocke
der ist käse in dieser soße war so ich
mache das immer so ich habe keinen
hunger mehr und dann im nächsten
grenzen erkennen und sie überwinden
lernen ist dass wir auch mit meinem hund
mit mikey verwirklicht also ist es super
gut gebraten rote trikots ist auch eine
empfehlung also es lohnt sich sehr hier
vorbeikommt genauso über unseren
nächsten jahr stehe ich euch jetzt zeige
und er kann auf meinem plan altstadt
gekommen hat aber ich muss sie in ihre
mitte nehmen weil es einfach zu gut ist
dieser sport hat auch legenden staat ja
soweit ich gehe in der lindenstadt ist
ein oder andere erkenntnis vielleicht
wir sind in einem supermarkt und
erfahren mit einer rolltreppe ich glaube
manche von euch wissen schon was das
heißt wir drüben steht zwar keine der
lieblings erfahrung die wir auf den
channel gemacht haben wir waren im
setzkasten essen hier auch in düsseldorf
und es ist wirklich eine erinnerung
geblieben ist es eric in erinnerung wie
mir in erinnerung braucht das erste mal
sterneköche auf dem kanal verstärker auf
dem kanal hat so eine welt geöffnet und
genau dafür ist es richtig mit dem mit
herz wo man für 55 euro ab fünf gänge
essen kann ist perfekt um einzusteigen
aber dazu gleich mehr mit diesem kasten
hier hat sich viel geändert auf meinem
kanal so werden die ersten erfahrungen
ich habe zuerst mal mit eric ein
restaurantbesuch und alles in allem
verbindet viel mit dem laden hier und
ich muss auch nicht sein ist eine
einzigartige möglichkeit um den zugang
zu guter küche zu trennen weil der
setzkasten der namensgebend ist hier als
39 euro aus einer sterneküche kriegt man
drei gänge 39 euro so das ist irre und
wenn man vorher noch ein bisschen
nachher noch ein bisschen vorne ein
bisschen business lunch 950 euro also
mit anderen worten das ist einfach die
möglichkeit um sterne küche für sich zu
entdecken oder ist einfach mal
auszuprobieren so ohne pleite zu sein
wenn man es am ende dann doch nicht
mochte weshalb mit anderen worten
lustig dass das wir gehofft dass gehört
das schon viele von euch auch hier war
mein letzter empfehlung für euch lohnt
sich sehr und damit habe ich glaub ich
ein ganz gutes bild gezeichnet was hier
so in düsseldorf möglich ist relativ
vielseitig auf jeden fall man muss schon
sagen auch als kölner dass düsseldorf
sehr viel zu bieten hat den arischen und
dank fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten
video auf und macht es gut